[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
mercredi 18 octobre 2022 le Sénat a
adopté à l'unanimité la proposition de
loi d'Elian assassies et d'Arnaud Bazin
encadrant l'intervention des cabinets de
conseils privés dans les politiques
publiques
ce texte met en oeuvre les
recommandations de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat dont le rapport a été
publié en mars dernier la commission
d'enquête avait révélé l'ampleur du
phénomène entre 2018 et 2021 les
dépenses de conseils de l'État ont plus
que doublé dépassant même le milliard
d'euros dans ce contexte la proposition
de loi s'articule autour de quatre
grands objectifs
il s'agit tout d'abord d'en finir avec
l'opacité des prestations de conseil
cela passe notamment par l'obligation
pour le gouvernement de recenser et
publier chaque année la liste des
prestations de conseils commandés par
les administrations ensuite le texte
encadre davantage le recours au
consultant par exemple en interdisant le
recours au Conseil à titre gratuit et en
imposant l'évaluation de toute
prestation la proposition de loi
renforce par ailleurs les obligations
déontologiques par exemple les
consultants devront transmettre une
déclaration d'intérêts en amont de leur
intervention un contrôle de la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique sera réalisée en particulier
quand un responsable public partent
exercer une activité de consultant dans
le secteur privé et réciproquement
enfin la proposition protège les données
de l'administration ainsi les données
collectées par le cabinet auprès de
l'administration ne pourront être
utilisés pour un autre objectif que
l'exécution de la prestation
elles devront par ailleurs être
détruites dans un délai d'un mois le
texte est désormais transmis à
l'Assemblée nationale
pour en savoir plus consultez le billet
de l'espace près
[Musique]